(logo whooshes)
(metal squeaks)
- [Narrator] I'm drinking at this party,
maybe four shots deep.
You ask if you can borrow $5 from me.
At this point, I'm drunk.
I don't say yes, or no,
I don't say anything at all.
If you take $5 from me,
even if I didn't explicitly say no,
you stole from me.
We're standing in line for the bathroom.
I ask you to hold my purse while I go in.
If you take $5 from my purse,
even though I trusted you to hold it,
you stole from me.
I'm on a dark street.
I feel a gun on the back of my head.
You ask me for $5 again.
Even if I physically
handed those $5 to you,
you stole from me.
We're out to breakfast and
you're short $5 for a coffee.
I lend it to you because we're friends,
and because you asked me.
The table next to us is short on cash too,
and they saw me lend you money.
If they go into my purse,
and assume they can have
$5, as well, without asking,
they stole from me.
I couple weeks later, you
ask to borrow $5 again.
This time, I don't wanna give it to you.
This time, I say no.
Just because I let you borrow $5 before,
that doesn't mean you can
take it whenever you want.
If you take it without asking,
you stole from me.
If you steal $5 from me, but
I cant' prove it in court,
you still stole from me.
Whatever the scenario,
you cannot take $5 from
me without my permission.
That's stealing.
Whatever the scenario,
you can't take my body without permission.
That's rape.
Consent is simple.
(slow mellow music)